used to be in the position
on the other side of the studio in terms
of getting a project made and now
you're on the producer side making the
movie
one of the reasons i enjoyed being an
executive was because i came at it from
a filmmaker's
standpoint one of the hard jobs of being
an executive inside
a big corporation is you go into a staff
meeting and
you're the advocate of the filmmaker and
the the company thinks that you're you
know a hippie who doesn't understand the
value of money and business
and then you go sit with the filmmakers
and you and you try to help them
see the um the way the company thinks
and you're a soulless corporate drone
who doesn't understand the value of art
and so you are sort of always in that
position
whether you're low level or high level
you're always sort of
um of two places to
to step over onto the producing side
which i've been doing now for 10 years
a little less um
i find it to be very helpful and there's
a there's a lot of
there's a lot of language which
companies don't which is coded
they don't know that it's coded because
for them it's how
people inside an organization speak to
each other same way government agencies
speak with a certain language and
whatever
i want to ask you the language you're
talking about is at the studio side
yeah okay yeah i think that there's a
and it takes a second to figure it out
so when i went to make a movie
at paramount i had to learn
the language uh that they that they were
using and what
what what the unspoken things were
between the lines and once you figure
that out
then you can really be a good partner to
them and try to figure out how everybody
can get what they want what they need
with disney it was very easy for me to
do that because i'd worked there for so
long and i knew so many of the people
and i knew um
i knew what this studio and what those
executives were having to deal with in
the
in regards to the rest of the company
what were the what were the pressure
points for them
and and so
it was um perhaps a little easier for me
to help guide the movie through um
through the system
so that they got what they needed but
also and more importantly is
that we were making the movie that we
wanted to make and that nikki
had all the support she needed um
to get where she needed to get to sure
when was this one of these projects that
in the scheme of things was quick to get
made or was this one of these things
that it's been a long journey it's been
a journey
got it yeah sure got it uh when did you
start on the project
uh to be honest i don't even remember
the date
but it was uh four years ago
i think five years ago now it's actually
not that bad they've been working on
bill and jen three for like 50 years
that is true that is true it took him 10
years to make yeah there's there's a lot
of movies that work a lot longer but
uh it just felt like we had a well we
had to
delay the start of the movie due to
casting and weather
and a bunch of stuff so we had to sort
of like rush to start
and then like a six-month lay back
and then shot the movie then we had all
this time
to post it and then
we had even more time so it just felt
like um it's it's felt like uh we've
been talking about mulan for a long time
during the development process how early
on did you know this was not going to
involve songs
from from the beginning from the get we
knew there would be music
but the idea fundamentally the idea was
to go back to the ballad
and to
pay homage to the animated classic and
the audience that loves it
but to really look at the whole breadth
of how these mulan stories have been
presented over the last you know 1500
years
and because the animated movie already
existed i think what we found really
exciting was
how do we use this as the
foundation on which to build a big
disney branded action adventure movie
how do you make a david lean movie or a
carousel movie or a johnny moe movie
with the disney brand and um
and so we thought that in order to
accomplish that and to get the kind of
emotional grounding we wanted
uh it needed to it should not be a break
in a song musical
i'm imagining you obviously have many
versions of the script along the way
was there ever really dramatic changes
in the script or was it always pretty
much
what we got what what i ended up seeing
well i think it constantly improved i
think the
the characters became more distinctly
drawn
um more importantly i think when
when nikki became involved
she really refocused everything
on the world through the eyes of mulan
and every every decision that was made
everything that we were doing was about
how do we put this in her
how do we focus on her journey through
all of this and so that
that was reflected in in changes to the
script
not massive like oh there used to be a
you know uh it used to be a set piece on
the great wall that we took out which
would
be uh anachronistic anyways but you know
there wasn't
big massive plot changes but there were
changes in terms of
how the characters are interacted and
where we focus the energy
of certain sequences in terms of the
production
that really is reflected in our in the
approach to the action
so we always talked about shooting the
action from the inside out
so yes it's a humongous set piece with
armies coming together
but what's the important part of that
the important part is
what is mulan's place in that and what
is her perception of what's going on
around her
and so telling her story inside of the
big set piece
um and that those two things
i think they didn't change the script or
change the story but they really changed
the approach and
ultimately i think the emotion and the
feeling that's evoked by the finished
film
uh obviously you've had a lot of
experience with test screenings
what was it like for you test screening
mulan uh
for the first time or the times you did
it and what did you learn from those
screenings
um well i learned that the audience
loves the story of that it just
resonates no matter how you tell it
whether you tell it with songs or you
tell it with big
battles it's a really powerful story
that
that sort of connects universally um
i think one of the interesting things
that came up in the testing was how
strongly men and boys
responded to the movie which we always
uh
assumed that they would enjoy it but we
always thought it might be a little
softer because of the female lead but it
it
it wasn't it was not appreciably so um
which i took as a as a really good sign
i learned people really really like
mushu
and if they are surprised that there's
no mushu
it's it's not always their happiest
moment but
um i think before
the marketing materials got out before
people knew
what it was uh it was it was a little
jarring for people
to see you know they thought that they
were gonna go see beauty and the beast
and they saw you know a big epic
action battle movie um so i think that
was jarring for the
like the initial test audiences but
once once there was a trailer out once
there were materials and people saw what
it was
then there was a lot of excitement did
you guys make
often with test screenings you learn
what's working what's not working
uh what changes did you guys work tweak
if you will
after all the test screenings or maybe
nothing um
no big story changes the the the biggest
takeaway was that
that people liked mulan that they just
really responded to ife
and they wanted to be with her more so
you know in those
as you're looking at those the balance
of
of the movie any opportunity we had to
put her
in put her on on from
front and center like they just really
wanted to see it
so they liked her journey and they liked
being with her
uh how long was your first cut compared
to the finished film
one hour and a half longer i think
now let's let's let's clarify that's
like an assembly
yeah all the footage so but there must
have been a cut after the assembly
that you know whether it be an early
director's cut with
you know a lot more footage i would say
about 45 minutes
now is that 45 minutes that you would be
happy for people to see
or that's like rough 45 minutes that's a
rough that's a rough 45 minutes like all
like all things i think once you once
you get it up the movie starts telling
you what it is too
that you know there's there's what you
do to the movie and then there's sort of
when
what the movie starts telling you it is
and and
what relationships resonate and and um
how much you need of certain
storytelling elements how much you need
uh how much action you need um all of
those so it's always a balance and
i i love the cut where it is i think it
plays
it plays really well there's nothing
that i can think of that i would there's
certainly nothing i would take out
i don't think there's any i mean listen
there's some great images
it's one of the reasons why they like i
was once told by a producer never to let
never let the editor on set because
you don't want them to know how hard
something was to do
right you want them to just judge the
footage
in the room what works in the movie what
doesn't because there's shots where i'm
like oh man we really hoofed it to do
like
that was expensive or that was really
hard to do or man was it cold that day
and you're like boy i just i wish i wish
that was in the movie not because we
needed it but because
uh it was so much work to get it
there's probably a couple of those and
there's some like stunning images
um that uh that we just didn't need
those scenes but that were really
beautiful
what was the what was the last sequence
you removed from the film before picture
locking and why
it's a really good question we didn't
remove a whole
sequence you know what actually it was
the last thing we changed was
additive we we added um
more action to the last
um sort of confrontation and we we
added more of the guys in the squad
because the audience really the audience
really just wanted
wanted more of them they had this great
emotional uh
there was both a big action and a big
emotional
ending for milan and by the time we get
to the
third act of the movie they've really
invested in her relationship with the
guys
and particularly with um hong wei played
by yosan and
and they've really invested in that so
there's um
they they kind of wanted to see a little
more of them in the end and so we
accommodated that
uh i'm very i guess i'm curious are you
going to release deleted scenes
for people that are fans of the movie um
that's really a disney question i don't
know we haven't we haven't we have all
the footage but we haven't
discussed that at some point
you're like maybe we are yeah maybe we
should get on that right away
uh so it's coming out on disney plus um
which is obviously not where it
originally was gonna go
and i viewed this as almost a test
bubble
for the entire streaming industry for
like will because it's a big it's a big
budget disney movie
this is not you know a 15 million dollar
film
um and the real question is um you know
will people pay
thirty dollars to watch this brand new
movie
on a platform that you know they're
paying for
but like to get this big movie first you
pay for it
um sort of like what what's your sort of
i know you produced it you obviously
want everyone to watch
but is it weird for you to sort of be
this test bubble
because if this works i can see disney
like
with the pixar movie soul or if this
works this
this could be you know they might say
well you know black widow
look how many people paid for mulan you
know we can
possibly do this with black widow well
you know i think the thing that's
somewhat disappointing to me
is the story about the movie in a lot of
ways has become about
uh distribution um
which you know nobody works five years
and stands out in the freezing cold rain
and whatever at four in the morning
because they're really excited about
reinventing distribution models i mean
maybe somebody does but
but not me um the uh
that said uh
you're right the thing i'm most excited
about is getting it out in front of
people because i think
um i think nikki made an amazing movie i
think ife
turned in a tremendous performance i
think every single department head did
awards quality work mandy walker is a
cinematographer
i mean she should be offered every movie
made from now on as far as i'm concerned
being a tagline costumes grant major
with um
with production design everybody just
did amazing work and i want people to
to see it when it comes to what it bodes
for the future
i don't know i uh you know netflix is
spending some pretty hefty dollars on
their original features
so it's not like we're an outlier in
terms of the size of a spend necessarily
um i think for me part of the difference
is
where we were just designed for a
theatrical release we have the
we have the equity in the ip we have
big stars globally you know it's sort of
custom made for global day and day
release
so it's different to do it on on disney
plus
or well the hybrid we're doing it
theatrically in a large number of
territories and where disney plus is
we're doing it on the the
premium video on demand i think that
it's just
i don't like to look at it as an
experiment but i i think we're
in this very unique moment where
i know families don't necessarily feel
comfortable going to a movie theater
right now
and i know in our house we're constantly
looking for ways to create an event
on our couch you know it's we've been
stuck inside with
a six-year-old and a four-year-old which
has been great in many ways but it's
also kind of tough like you
this is the time when you want to be
taking them to the zoo and
you want to be giving your kids these
amazing memorable moments
and unfortunately it's harder and harder
to do
than than it was so for me obviously
this is different because
the kids have seen the movie and
whatever but like the idea of being able
to have
a big movie night watch a big movie a
new movie
an exciting movie um yeah on your couch
with your family
if there's more than three if there's
three of you or more then it's a
it's a bargain uh as opposed to going to
the theater itself i think there's
something really
kind of great about it i hope that
people watch it
um i know that over the lifetime of the
movie a lot a lot of people will watch
it but i
i hope that i hope that it's
uh people are able to
have fun and enjoy and connect as a
family and still have a communal
film-going experience and and
you know every day sadly the movies
themes become more and more
sort of relevant like it's even shifted
like originally it was like well this is
about someone finding their place
and how do you overcome all these great
obstacles and and now
in my mind even it was always about
family
and now it's even more so like that part
of it is resonating to me even more
because
we're trying to figure out how to be
parents and how to be kids
and how to be you know partners with all
of the craziness that's going on
and it's an it's an example of someone
who does it
not easily but does it with with grace
and style so
i hope that i hope people watch it i
hope they take away i'm sure people are
going to watch that's i mean
you guys made something that i believe
families
will really enjoy and also it
is um important to see stories
representation matters
and this is us you know everything about
this is i'm very happy disney made this
movie
um it's just but i i am curious because
the industry is changing
so radically over the pandemic over
covid that
it's just it's i'm very curious how our
people
you know what i mean people who are
absolutely well i think here's the thing
i
i think that it's i think that the
pandemic
is accelerating trends that were already
um happening and it just made them
come about a lot it made people more
willing to try new things and to
and to sort of discard tradition in
order to be a little more dynamic i
don't i'm a
i am a true blue believer in the
theatrical film-going experience
i think to watch uh a big action movie
on the big screen
there's nothing like it i think to watch
a comedy in a room full of people
i i can't even imagine that some of my
favorite
moments in my life are watching the
audience reaction to
to a movie whether it's whether it's
star wars episode 4 or whether it's a
big action
another big action movie or a quite
honestly like
just watching an audience laugh
it's just so great i can't imagine that
goes away
however i think the whole model is going
to become a lot more dynamic
and they'll start tailoring the
distribution
to the to the material itself so whether
it's a window
a theatrical window or a simultaneous
window with streaming
or streaming release with a theatrical
window
after the fact i think that there's just
uh
no no no limit to the ways that they're
going to use it
i think it creates a a challenge for
creative teams i'm going to stop here
and just say congrats on mulan
thank you i really do hope it's a huge
hit and people
you know watch it and that um everyone's
happy
um and i do appreciate you sharing some
of those stories about you know early
days at disney and uh making you know
some of those projects
well great thank you steven it's great
to talk to you i love sitting and
talking with with film fans
it's always great